cold I love my business outside I'll
take a jab you on tranquilizer both work
+4 which one is the business I don't
know you well enough you know you know
what I mean they both work which one do
you want to do I would like to try to
thicken up - you prefer Gaby ok well
that's why you're asking which one will
you do
I wouldn't take either could you do this
I can't answer that for you Peters
holding you back you know what you want
to do the only reason you're not doing
is because they're scared of doing what
you actually want to do right are you
scared to do it cuz your parents won't
like it
you know my buddy okay so when you scare
the family I'm not failing the building
at the same place when my friends are at
the next level huge mistake you don't
want the same thing your friends want so
why the [ __ ] you care what they have
number one mistake so many people make
it they care about what other people
have I don't give a [ __ ] what anybody
has if I have more buy less as a matter
I worry about myself the fact that
you're worrying about other people's
accomplishments is already a losing
formula you need to get rid of that
first then you can focus on yourself you
understand
[Music]